AS EXPECTED THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE INVESTIGATING
DESHAUN WATSON IN THE
AFTERMATH OF MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS FILED ALLEGING
ASSAULT DURING MASSAGE AND
COUNTERS ATTORNEY. TONY BUZZ
BE POSTING ON SOCIAL MEDIA
THE LETTER CLEARLY MARKED
CONFIDENTIAL FILES LISA FREE
EXPLAINING THAT NUMBER ONE.
THE INVESTIGATION IS LAUNCHED
A NUMBER TWO, THEY WOULD LIKE
THE
WITH THE INVESTIGATION. RATE
THAT'S ONE OF THE GREAT FLAWS
AND WEAKNESSES OF THE NFL'S
PROCESS MOUTH. THERE'S NO WAY
THEY CAN COMPEL ANYONE TO
COOPERATE AND THE FACT THAT
THE LETTER WAS PLACED ON
BEEN VERY VERY ACTIVE ON  HAS
INSTAGRAM WITH HIS
INVOLVEMENT IN THESE CASES. I
SUSPECT THAT THAT HE WILL
ENCOURAGE HIS CLIENTS TO
COOPERATE WITH THE NATIONAL
FOOTBALL LEAGUE UNLESS OF
NO, MAN, I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S
TOO LATE FOR THAT. BUT IF
THERE'S A SETTLEMENT WITH AN
AGREEMENT TO NOT TALK ABOUT
IT, WHICH IS PERFECTLY
LEGITIMATE. IT HAPPENS ALL
THE TIME. THERE'S
CONFIDENTIALITY PROVISIONS IN
POWER FOR THE NFL TO TALK TO
THESE PEOPLE THAT BE NOTHING
THE NFL COULD DO TO DESHAUN
WATSON AND WITH NINE NOW THAT
ARE SIGNED UP BY TONY BUSBY
AND BUSBY HAS SAID THAT SEVEN
LAWSUITS HAVE BEEN FILED
WE'VE SEEN THREE OF THEM IS
GONNA BE A PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY. THEY ALL FLOW.
FROM THESE ALLEGATIONS OF
SOME LEVEL OR DEGREE OF
MISCONDUCT AND THERE ARE
VARYING LEVELS AND DEGREES OF
ALLEGED MISCONDUCT DURING
PRIVATE MASSAGE SESSIONS AND
SAYING YESTERDAY THE TAKEAWAY
FOR EVERY OTHER PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETE OR ANYONE WHO HAS ANY
ASSETS THAT COULD BE AT RISK
DO NOT PUT YOURSELF IN THESE
POSITIONS WHERE IT ULTIMATELY
WORD AGAINST SOMEONE ELSE'S
WAY TO PROVE THAT. YOUR WORD
IS THE TRUE WORD. YES, EXACTLY
AND THAT IS WHY I THINK A LOT
OF TEAMS HAVE MASSEUSES
SET UP IN THE TRAINING ROOM,
RIGHT? THERE ARE WAYS THAT
THIS CAN HAPPEN THROUGH THE
TEAM AND SO THAT'S PART OF
WHY BECAUSE IT HELPS KEEP
EVERYBODY PROTECTED FROM THE
MASSEUSE AND YOU KNOW, WHO IS
COULD IT POTENTIALLY BECOME
UNCOMFORTABLE JUST BASED ON
THE WAY THAT PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES NEED TO KEEP THEIR
FROM THE ATHLETES STANDPOINT
WHERE YOU KNOW, YOU ARE
GETTING THE PROTECTION OF YES,
THIS IS ALL ABOVE BOARD AND
THIS BECAUSE IT IS, YOU KNOW
PROVIDED BY THE TEAM THERE IS
NO WAY THAT SOMETHING CAN
POSSIBLY BE MISINTERPRETED.
SO I THINK YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT. YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE
YOU KNOW THAT YOU ARE
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE OF THAT
CANNOT HAPPEN WHERE THERE IS
SOME SORT OF ALLEGED
AND LOOK THE REALITY IS
VICTIMS. THERE ARE THE HARDER
IT IS TO CONVINCE THE AVERAGE
PERSON WITH WITH NO
PREDISPOSITIONS WITH NO
YOU JUST HEAR THE NUMBERS AND
AT A CERTAIN POINT. I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE OVER/UNDER IS,
BUT AT A CERTAIN POINT THE
NUMBERS OVERPOWER THE
INDIVIDUAL DENIAL DENIAL
DENIAL AT A CERTAIN POINT
THERE'S TOO MANY TO GET THE
AVERAGE PERSON TO SAY
ANYTHING OTHER THAN THAT'S
THIS ISN'T GOOD NOW. THAT
IT'S POSSIBLE. IT'S POSSIBLE
AT THIS POINT THAT HE WILL
PREVAIL IN EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF THESE CASES AND AGAIN SOME
CASES STRONGER THAN OTHERS AS
IT RELATES TO THE ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT. THE FIRST LAWSUIT
YOU CAN SAY EVEN IF ALL THIS
IS TRUE, WHAT WHAT
IT'S THE ASSAULT THE SECOND
LAWSUIT HAD SOME REAL AT THAT
SAME ELEMENT TO IT THE THIRD
LAWSUIT A LITTLE MORE
TROUBLING AT LEAST BASED ON
THE ALLEGATIONS. NOW WHETHER
OR NOT THERE WAS ALLEGATIONS
CAN BE PROVEN THAT REMAINS TO
BE SEEN AND WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO IT WILL BE THE
TESTIMONY OF THE SHOT
ASSUMING THIS GOES ALL THE
WAY THROUGH TO A TRIAL ANY OF
ALL NINE FILED APPARENTLY ESE
SEVEN HAVE BEEN FILED IN
THERE'S A PRESS CONFERENCE
TODAY. WE'RE TONY BUSBY'S
GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE CASE
AND GIVE OUT COPIES OF THE
COMPLAINTS AND SHOW SOME TEXT
MESSAGES MORE ON THAT IN A
SECOND. BUT YOU HAVE THE
TESTIMONY OF DESHAUN WATSON
THE TESTIMONY OF THE ALLEGED
VICTIM PRESUMABLY NO OTHER
WITNESSES TO ANY OF THESE
ENCOUNTERS AND THEN THE ONLY
OBJECTIVE EVIDENCE THE ONLY
UNDENIABLE EVIDENCE ANY TEXT
MESSAGES OR OTHER DIGITAL
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE
WATSON SO LAST NIGHT THERE
WERE TWO SUCH MESSAGES CHAINS
OF MESSAGES RELEASED BY TONY
BUSBY AND MY
REACTION WAS AT THIS IS THE
BEST YOU GOT THESE MESSAGES
AREN'T GOING TO HELP YOU IF
ANYTHING THEY'RE GOING TO
HURT YOU IF YOU THINK IT'S A
SMOKING GUN AND IT'S NOT A
SMOKING GUN IN YOUR TOUTING.
THIS IS A SMOKING GUN THAT
MAKES YOUR ENTIRE
PRESENTATION LESS CREDIBLE
PERSON MORE INCLINED TO
BELIEVE THE ONE WHO'S BEING
ACCUSED AND THE BEST EXAMPLE
APPLE THERE'S A TEXT CHAIN
WHERE
DESHAUN WATSON ASKS THE
WITH THE GLUTE AREA AND TABLE
APPARENTLY THAT'S THAT'S THE
YOU COMFORTABLE WITH THE
GLUTE AREA? LIKE THAT'S SOME
IMPROPER REQUEST. THAT'S NOT
AN UNCOMMON AREA FOR AN
ATHLETE TO NEED TO HAVE A
MASSAGE SIMS TALKED ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY BEFORE WE KNEW
ANYTHING ABOUT THESE TEXT
MESSAGES THAT THE GROIN IN
THE GLUTE AREA REQUIRES WORK
ESPECIALLY FOR A FOOTBALL
PLAYER WITH ALL THE CROUCHING
AND MOVING AND AND YOU NEED
THOSE.
AREAS TO BE LOOSENED UP AND
SOME MASSEUSES ARE
COMFORTABLE. SOME ARE NOT
HE ASKED THE QUESTION. ARE
YOU COMFORTABLE IF ANYTHING,
THAT'S A TEXT MESSAGE DID
HIS LAWYER WOULD BE RELEASING
AS PROOF THAT NOTHING
HAPPENED. SO I WAS BLOWN AWAY
WHEN THAT'S THE ONE WHEN YOU
GO TO TONY DUNNE. TONY
IN HER, BUT WHAT'S IT CALLED
INSTAGRAM INSTAGRAM PAGE
INSTA FACE.
FILE WELL SMASH FACE IS BILL
BELICHICK WOULD SAY AND AND
YOU SEE THAT THERE YOU LOOK
AT AND YOU SAY
WHAT DO YOU WHAT ARE YOU
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
UNLESS YOU HAVE A FUNDAMENTAL
MISUNDERSTANDING OF WHAT GOES
ON DURING A MASSAGE WHICH HE
POSSIBLY DOES AND WHICH
POSSIBLY SOME OF THESE NOVICE
MASSEUSES HAVE THERE'S
THERE'S NOTHING THERE THAT
SHOWS ANY WRONGDOING.
YEAH, THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
THOUGHT TOO BECAUSE
OSTENSIBLY HE'S ASKING FOR
CONSENT THERE. AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY WOULD
ENCOURAGE. YOU KNOW, YOU WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
IS COMFORTABLE WITH THE WAY
THINGS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
HAPPEN IN A PROFESSIONAL
ATHLETES MASSAGE, AND I THINK
IF YOU LOOK AT THAT OTHER INK
SERIES OF TEXTS, I MEAN THE
ONLY THING THAT'S THERE IS I
APOLOGIZE IF YOU FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE. IT WASN'T MY
INTENTION NOW THAT COULD BE
INTERPRETED IN A NUMBER OF
WAYS, BUT I THINK IT'S
THE SAME SORT OF THING. IT'S
NOT NECESSARILY A SMOKING GUN
AT LEAST AT THIS POINT NOW IS
WHETHER THAT SECOND SERIES OF
TEXTS THAT WAS POSTED WAS
BEFORE HE SENT THE FIRST
SERIES OF TEXTS WHETHER IT
WAS AFTER IT WHETHER IT WAS
TO THE SAME PERSON, YOU KNOW
IT BECAUSE THERE OSTENSIBLY
ON TWO DIFFERENT PLATFORMS
THAT FIRST SERIES LOOK LIKE
THEY WERE INSTAGRAM GM'S AND
THAT'S THESE ARE TWO
DIFFERENT TWO DIFFERENT
PEOPLE TWO DIFFERENT PEOPLE.
COME ON. YES, RIGHT THE
AND I DIDN'T NOTICE THIS AT S
FIRST AND THIS IS MY OWN
IDIOCY WHEN IT COMES TO
INSTAGRAM THAT THERE CAN BE A
SECOND PAGE TO IT WHEN I
CLICK THE BUTTON AND SAW THE
SECOND ONE. IT REFERS TO AN
ALLEGATION THAT WAS MADE IN
WAS A TEXT MESSAGE AFTER THE
FACT WHERE WATSON APOLOGIZED
AND WHAT HE SAID IS SORRY
ABOUT YOU FEELING
UNCOMFORTABLE NEVER WERE THE
INTENTIONS. LET ME KNOW IF
FUTURE MY APOLOGIES.
NOW AGAIN IN THE CONTEXT OF
INTIMATE ACT DID IT END AND
THERE ARE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
YOU NEED TO HAVE MASSAGED AND
IF YOU'RE NOT COMFORTABLE
AHEAD OF TIME AND YOU AND YOU
AND YOU FIND OUT DURING THE
MASSAGE THE PERSON ISN'T
COMFORTABLE THAT THAT
REASONABLY LEADS TO THAT KIND
OF EXCHANGE. SO THIS ISN'T
THE CLASSIC APOLOGY THAT YOU
WOULD POINT TO, YOU KNOW
THEY APOLOGIZED. THEY MUST BE
AT FAULT. NO, THIS IS THIS IS
A REASONABLE IN THE CONTEXT
APOLOGY THAT
IT WOULD BE MADE BY SOMEONE
WHO NEEDED AN AREA MASSAGE
THAT THE PERSON PROVIDING
MASSAGE WASN'T COMFORTABLE
PROVIDING. IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
YES IT IS. AND SO THAT'S WHY
THIS AS YOU WERE JUST SAYING,
IT'S NOT THE SMOKING GUN THAT
SOME MIGHT THINK IT IS JUST
BASED ON WHAT THE CONTEXT IS
OF A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETES
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER NOW THE
OTHER PART OF THAT IS IT
DIDN'T DO ANYTHING, RIGHT?
SO THERE THERE'S JUST SORT OF
NOTHING THAT WE CAN
DEFINITIVELY SAY FROM THESE
TWO SERIES OF MESSAGES THAT
DESHAUN WATSON SENT ALLEGEDLY
TO THESE YOUNG WOMEN SO THAT
BUT IF THAT'S WHAT YOUR
TOUTING IF THAT'S WHAT YOUR
TOUTING NO, BUT THAT'S WHAT
CONCERNS ME IS IF THAT'S THE
BEST YOU'VE GOT. WHAT ARE YOU
DOING? WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
WHAT? WHY WHY ARE YOU WHY ARE
YOU WHY ARE YOU MAKING THIS
IT'S A BIG DEAL UNLESS THE
UNLESS HE'S JUST TRYING TO
REDUCE OUR EXPECTATIONS. AND
CONFERENCE IS GOING TO BE
TEXT MESSAGES THAT ARE FAR
MORE DAMNING. BUT IF THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT HE'S
HE'S GOING TO REVEAL TODAY,
DID THIS ISN'T WHAT YOU THINK
POSSIBLE THAT TONY BUSBY
HAS YET TO DEVELOP THE
EXPERTISE NECESSARY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENS DURING
THE MASSAGE UPPER OF A
PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE. I
GUARANTEE YOU THIS NUMBER ONE.
DESHAUN WATSON IS NOT GOING
TO BACK DOWN TO SEAN WATSON
WILL SPEND WHATEVER MONEY IS
NECESSARY TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
I THINK THE POINT OF
POTENTIAL SETTLEMENT IS LONG
GONE, EVEN IF THE PLAINTIFFS
AT THIS
POINT WOULD STILL WANT ONE
DESHAWN IS GIRDING FOR A
FIGHT. HE'S HIRED RUSTY
HARDEN WHO HAS REPRESENTED
OF ROGER CLEMENS AND DESHAUN
WATSON. I BELIEVE IS PART OF
THE MONEY THAT WILL BE SPENT
ON THIS ON THIS DEFENSE WILL
INCLUDE OTHER PEOPLE WHO HAVE
GIVEN HIM A MASSAGE HAS
PEOPLE FROM THE TEXANS EXPERT
WITNESSES ON WHAT THIS ALL
MEANS AND WHAT HAPPENS DURING
A MASSAGE AND HOW CERTAIN
THINGS ARE NORMAL AND CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES ARE REQUESTED
ATHLETES AND SPECIFICALLY
THAT DESHAUN WATSON ROUTINELY
HAS MASSAGES IN THE AREAS
THAT THAT SOME MAY FIND
THE PROCESS OF THAT MASSAGE.
THERE MAY BE INCIDENTAL
CONTACT WITH OTHER THINGS
THAT AREN'T PART OF THE
MASSAGE. SO AGAIN, LIKE YOU
SAID, NONE OF THIS MEANS HE'S
INNOCENT, BUT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT'S BEEN RELEASED YET.
SHOWS HE'S NOT
AND YOU KNOW THE ALLEGATIONS
ARE JUST THAT THEY WILL BE
SUBJECT TO EFFORTS TO PROVE
THAT THEY'RE NOT ACCURATE
MISTAKEN EMBELLISHED
FABRICATED, WHATEVER BUT I
COME BACK TO THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE NINE. IT'S STILL
NOT GOING TO BE EASY FOR
DESHAUN WATSON TO PROVE THAT
NINE DIFFERENT. PEOPLE ARE
ARE WRONG. BUT BUT HERE'S
WHERE THERE'S A BENEFIT MILES
BECAUSE IT'S ONE LAWYER WHO'S
REPRESENTING ALL OF THEM,
OBVIOUS FROM HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
ACTIVITY THAT THIS LAWYER HAS
A DESIRE TO GET TO SEAN
WATSON IF THEY CAN IN JUST
ONE OF THOSE NINE CASES JUST
ONE.
POSE A BIG LIE EXPOSE A
SMOKING GUN THAT GOES THE
OTHER WAY THAT CAUSES ALL
NINE TO CRUMBLE IN. THE
FIRST THING THAT I WOULD DO
IF I WAS THE LAWYER
REPRESENTING DESHAUN WATSON
IS I WOULD GO INTO COURT WITH
A MOTION TO CONSOLIDATE ALL
NINE CASES INTO ONE. YOU
BITES AT THE APPLE. YOU DON'T
WANT NINE DIFFERENT CHANCES.
CASE, LET'S GO BECAUSE THEN
YOU ONLY HAVE TO SHOW THAT
ONE IS
A COMPLETE AND TOTAL LIAR IF
YOU CAN AND AGAIN THIS IS ALL
I'M NOT SAYING WHO'S RIGHT .
WHO'S WRONG, BUT IF YOU GET
IT ALL INTO ONE CASE, IF ONE
OF THOSE NINE DOESN'T HOLD UP,
IF ONE OF THOSE NINE CAN BE
PROVEN TO BE LYING. YOU DON'T
TO PROVE POTENTIALLY THAT THE
OTHER EIGHT ARE BECAUSE THE
WHOLE THE WHOLE THING IS
TAINTED AT THAT POINT NOW ONE
BAD APPLE SPOILS THE ENTIRE
BUNCH AND THAT'S WHY IT IS
IMPORTANT. I THINK FROM THE
LEGAL STRATEGY STANDPOINT IS
TO DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING? I MEAN IF
YOU'RE DESHAUN WATSON THAT
YOU BASICALLY KNOW THAT
MAKE YOURSELF LOOK THE CAN
ABSOLUTE BEST BECAUSE IF THAT
IS THE CASE WHERE THERE IS
THE BIG LIE, AND YOU HAVE ONE
IS NOT IN FACT AN ALLEGED HO
VICTIM AND YOU KNOW, YOU SEE
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT COME ABOUT THEN. YES,
PLAY THIS IN TERMS OF A LEGAL
STRATEGY BECAUSE THAT
IS EXACTLY HOW HE'S PROBABLY
GOING TO BE SEEN BEST AT
LEAST IN THE PUBLIC EYE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE NINE, YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT. THERE'S JUST
THE SEGMENT, YOU KNOW, WHAT
IS THE OVER-UNDER? WHO KNOWS
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO A CERTAIN
POINT IT JUST BY SHEER
NUMBERS, IT'S ALMOST HARD TO
SAY. WELL, WAIT A MINUTE.
THERE MUST BE SOMETHING GOING
ON HERE, BUT THAT DOESN'T
CASE JUST BECAUSE THE  THE
QUANTITY IS UP. IT DOESN'T
IS SOMETHING LL RIGHT. LET'S TA